the met office has warned that this
winter could be wetter than normal with
households urged to be prepared for the
risk of flooding climate change means
that the uk can expect heavier and more
intense rainfall that change will
continue over the next few decades
whether or not we're on a path to net
zero so is the uk prepared for a wetter
future well the environment agency says
1.5 million households are in flood risk
areas but haven't got any preparations
julia that's not a good figure to be
starting with how do you improve and
increase resilience and preparedness
gosh um
but of course the environment agency has
a very good flood and coastal erosion
risk management strat fully funds them
to deliver it but of course they can't
protect us from everything and we need
to uh to do some things for ourselves so
we need to make sure that everybody is
is signed up for flood warnings uh if
they live in an area that has that is um
at risk of flooding and we need to make
sure that people understand the kind of
precautions they should be taking so for
example
if there's a
significant risk
then they should have a bag packed they
should make sure they have their
medicines ready they should make sure
they can either move
precious things upstairs if necessary
they should be prepared to leave the
house taking their pets with them those
sorts of things but but in general we
need to be designing um both our homes
and our cities to uh to take into
account that there will be much more
water around so we need to take on board
what the chinese are doing which is
they're designing sponge cities cities
that are designed to absorb water
because as we heard earlier we're going
to be getting more periods of very
intense rainfall which can lead to
surface water flooding in our cities and
that's probably one of the types of
flooding we are least well prepared for
in the uk at the moment
george
whose responsibility is it to ensure
that we're prepared is it government or
is it individual responsibility
well there's not much that we can do by
ourselves we do need government to
intervene and we need it to be far more
effective than it has been so far i'm
slightly puzzled by the focus the
particular focus that a lot of people
have on
how we
absorb water in cities
as julia has just been discussing
because of course cities are just a very
small part of a river's catchment and
they're at the bottom of the catchment
we also need to be intensely focused on
what's happening in the rest of that
catchment how well is the land absorbing
and holding back the rain how well are
the rivers slowing down the flow
and if as we've so often done we've
canalized and dredged the rivers we tend
to speed up the flow towards the cities
until it hits the nearest urban pinch
point and then bursts its bank what we
need to do is have rivers which hold
back the water for as long as possible
so that they allow the the flow to be
attenuated to be slowed down to come
down instead of in one great big pulse
in a long slow flow and that means
allowing them once more to meander to
braid to form islands and other
obstructions that just slow that water
down similarly on the hillsides let's
get some trees back let's get some um
terracing in in in important places
let's do everything we can to slow down
the flow throughout the entire catchment
rather than sitting there like rabbits
in the headlight
waiting for this great wall of water to
come down and hit us and then wondering
what to do about it yeah sitting ducks i
guess julia are we getting the focus
wrong then when we when we prioritize
cities and our planning around cities
george arguing that we need to take our
focus further upstream
and no we need uh we need all of those
things i was particularly talking about
surface water flooding which is the
response to periods of short short
relatively short periods of very intense
rainfall so it's not water in cities
it's not water coming from the rivers
it's actually the water coming from the
sky and and surface water flooding is
something we are less well prepared for
in the uk than we are for for coastal
flooding and river flooding but george
is right of course we should be using
nature-based solutions um to try and
slow down the the rate at which water
comes into our rivers when we have wet
weather so those sorts of things are
very important as well
george are there other areas i know
particularly you've talked about canada
british columbia where we should be
looking to
it's really shocking what's happening
there i mean it's a classic case of a
compound climate disaster so so as you
know there was this massive heat dome
over that region of western canada and
the western us
in the summer and there were huge fires
those not only destroyed a lot of trees
they also helped to bake the soil all
that ensures that water runs off it more
and now we see this massive dump of
rainfall you know probably also
exacerbated by climate breakdown and a
lot of the communities in british
columbia are now flooded and in some
cases that flood water has frozen and is
likely to remain frozen for the whole
winter so what they're going to do
i mean it's just it's almost
unimaginable the situation that some
communities are in it's really really
horrible and i'm surprised there's so
little coverage of it in the news at the
moment